Chase Sapphire the credit card but they
also pay for your TSA and Global Entry
I have a
what's on sign up huh it's on sign up
[Music]
welcome back to another amazing episode
of the careful boys today we have
Lawrence Cal back in the building wow
I like your shirt Lawrence this is a
Playboy is it an official Playboy merch
or is it parody
um actually I don't know gilded this
guy's kind of a Playboy himself we hear
you're kind of a Playboy oh official
Playboy I was expecting each look it's a
cool shirt something I was expecting
something a little more horny a little
more risque yeah this is so innocent
they're just spreading little mopeds
they are rebranding are they I don't
know oh well
um
Joe's tired because he missed his flight
last night he came in this morning at
7am dude that's wild yeah
what happened so uh did you guys know
you have to check in your flight before
you get on the plane I didn't know that
like such a like common thing to do
it okay it happened to me too one time
when I didn't check in but all they did
was like bump me down from like a first
class seat to a a lower tier
really maybe sorry you didn't check in
like so you're like see he's just empty
in first class and you just no I think
someone else like hopped onto it or
something that's nice so how like when
when did you check in though I did
that's a huge deal how did you get in
that's a lot of money no I checked in
like when I got there I didn't check him
beforehand right wait so that's that's
the thing you didn't even check and
check it I went up to the TSA pre-check
and they said boarding pass and I was
like oh yeah I didn't check in and then
like like the flight was like 12.
all right the flight was like 12 20. it
was taken off 12 20 right I was there
like 11 50. boarding is probably what
1205. yeah no boarding school no
boarding was like 11 40.
or whatever so so I was I always do this
though like that's perfect timing if I
checked in I could walk in in like 10
minutes I'm good to go do you always not
check in no it's my first time okay but
I also didn't know that like you had to
check in
I thought it was just like you're
checking in because you're like hey save
my seat bro why you laughing right what
I don't know
anyways I okay I go up there I try to
check it in my app and they're like oh
you can't do this at this moment so I'm
like all right [__] so I go to the kiosk
and they're like go see a a a a front
desk person I go to the front desk and
I'd be like
this is when I knew that front desk
people always have to deal with people
that are like high like stressed and
yelling at them and [__] because all I
said was
um I was like it's telling me to go to
the front desk and I can't get in and
I'm like my flight hasn't left yet and
she goes oh and she goes yeah you're not
gonna be able to get on the plane
there's nothing I can do she started
making all these excuses and [__] and I
was just like
not one of those man I'm just chill and
then oh after I was like prepping to
like deal with your anger yeah and I and
I was just confused because I was like
but the plane hasn't left yet and then
she explained to me that if you
there's a cut off time
so if you don't check in before the
cutoff time it's shut down because they
assume that you just never came yeah so
they probably gave up my seat or
something yeah
you have to check in before boarding
sounds pretty common sense right but I
don't have common sense so I was there
and I was like it worked so so far up to
like yeah for 38 years because you fly a
lot like I fly a lot so I should know
these things right yeah
but I I also never like
slipped my mind to never check this is
my first time never checking in like
I'll check in and miss a flight you do
the 24-hour check-in I used to it I just
I don't know just this whole week I've
been scatter brains right so then I get
to the front and then as this is this is
also why you should never like flip out
on flight like the the people because if
you're nice to them they're like oh this
Fool's different they hook you up she
tried her best to get me on she was
calling her manager oh he doesn't even
have bags chicken he could just walk in
right now they're like sorry honey you
know the system's off and then she try
to you know yeah you never did this
before she's like I'm sorry I can't do
anything for you I'm like you only had
to try so hard and I was like all right
well uh what what can I do because you
know they can book you on the next
flight and then she was like
it's all booked up they have we have
negative seats and I'm like how do you
get Negative seats
that's what you want to hear she has
negative seats that means like they
booked more people always happens though
like why do they always do that like
over a book flights because people like
me they they know Bank on the fact that
someone's gonna miss it yeah there
probably is I bet it happens there's
probably a large ratio like frequently
right when they're like all right this
is a fully booked flight if anybody
would like to uh give up their seat you
will get a 300 voucher and a hotel you
know what I mean they like do that
pretty frequently yeah they did a lot
yeah I think they probably masked it out
over the years on like the probability
of how many people missing flights out
of the group and then they just know but
then like
yeah so after that I just booked a
flight going home
and then I said I mean I'm going to La
but I had to do a red eye
I saw him explain this very slow because
I barely slept
I had to go to Maui first that was
pretty wild oh dang yeah how's that what
was that like uh I got footage of
Lahaina just all gone it's all gone bro
that's so crazy dog it is crazy like
it's wild man just seen those pictures
man is [__] up yeah my my um my family
loser but they were they were like off
Island during that whole time
but then I was going in and it was just
a weird vibe there too uh there were
people traveling still or like
connecting but then the energy was
different how many tourists did you see
going to Maui excited to take their
vacation amount I mean I did still see
tourists and I saw like
I don't know like a lot of different
um foreign groups I think maybe they
booked their plans way ahead and then
they like they're speaking like French
Spanish or whatever they're speaking
French kick them out there's like
Europeans yeah
so maybe they had like a huge thing
booked up I don't know well even with
like you know like there's there's so
many conversations about how like um so
much of Maui's economy is based off of
like tourism right so like they still
need people to come in in order to like
help support so many of the people who
have
who have work that are like completely
around you know tourist stuff even my my
sister in law who lives there
and and her husband like you know he
works with like different restaurants
and like those those some restaurants
got burned down and stuff like that you
know what I mean uh or she works with
like helicopter tourism out there and
it's like now you know like if people
don't come if people don't pay for those
things like those crashed out as well
you know so it's kind of like it's a
huge doubler sword yeah kind of
conundrum right yeah
I think so
[Laughter]
yeah yeah good good yeah well you made
it you're a little sleepy but you made
it at 9 40. got on the flight and then I
I fell asleep but I treated myself
because I said I'm gonna get myself a
business class so I could rest but it
was a recliner so I was like this
it went from here and it went like this
no no that's that's optimal though
that's great that's great for a flight
perfect amount you need now you could
just shut up I was thinking that the
whole time I was like man American
Airlines out of all the domestic flight
is probably the cheapest one because
even Delta got better recliners than
this bro it also is good bro American is
a little funny dog [__] Delta loses
my bag all the time oh really really
yeah I like Delta I like Delta too and I
hate United United Delta and American
which ones Delta Delta um Delta's number
one though I think so American Airlines
almost made us miss our flight like
crazy when we got to do a connecting
from uh LA to Dallas and I got delayed
like three hours and everyone in the
terminal like it was a red eye everyone
in the terminal in American Airlines was
all heading towards the customer service
because like oh damn dude and I was like
oh no I'd hate to be those people as an
R flight got delayed like three hours so
we didn't get on the plane until like 2
A.M it was [__] awful anybody got
airport or airplane hacks or tips you
should check in a day before
check your email do the check-in do that
yeah get the business class recliner
where you can go through how often do
you guys miss your flights though never
I've only missed my flight once and it
was when we were kids the flight really
ah yeah I got this three times but you
fight a lot though huh but they're like
stupid reasons like what's the dumbest
reason it was like a layover it was a
connecting flight and then we were like
let's go smoke a cigarette in the
cigarette Lounge last time I missed our
flight damn wow sounds pretty dumb super
super dumb me and uh Bart missed our
flight because we were eating Carl's Jr
at the airport and we did hear our thing
beings yeah it's pretty dumb they were
just talking were you guys were you guys
in at the gate we were next to the gate
and we were like oh we could see the
gate so we're [__] eating Carl's Jr
just talking and then we're like oh
maybe we should go to our what are you
guys talking about
how good the Carl's Jr is oh yummy so we
were on time it was boarding but then it
was such a small flight that they just
were like oh I guess no one else is here
and we're like we see the plane let us
on and they're like where'd he close the
door
when we used to fly with like all Quest
Crew Victor would always like when we're
waiting for the um the gate to open he
would just go lay down like freaking
hell of far put headphones on and just
sleep expecting us to wake him up and
we're like [__] out we're not waking
that fool up
hey is he one of those guys yeah is he
one of those guys that sleeps on the
floor
I like to trip over him on accident dude
I used to be that guy that's so funny
yeah like I would always just lay down
with my duffel bag like I like to trip
on those people oh [__] sorry yeah it
was you [__]
one of the stupidest things I've done
was um I booked a plane ticket
like
from Honolulu to here when I was here
so I basically yeah that's an airplane
too but it was so funny and then I got
dude the thing is I got in yeah like I I
got in security everything and then I
was just like yo it says my [__] is
boarding right now and then I was like
I'm in the right gate am I wait it says
oh crap it says Honolulu to L.A and I'm
like I'm in L.A what the [__] and you
were able to go through everything too
yeah that's why and then this is not
necessarily looking at it oh yeah that's
true
when you go through TSA like you just
give your ID now so as long as you the
ID goes ding so really they check my
ticket always no no the front person
checks you have a boarding pass to make
sure you can go into the TSS the right
gate okay but they're just looking that
you have a ticket not necessarily like
they're not like cross-referencing yeah
they're looking like okay you're
obviously going to America and this is
America and you have your ticket okay
you can pass well I I have pre-check and
they just give you you just give them
the ID and then when you get the ID it
and it just has goes to it has to go
Ding and then they get the ID back up
that's a tip get preaching I need to get
free check I need a preset too yeah but
it comes with global entry
Global Entry is like the sickest thing a
little entry would be great for you it's
a hundred bucks for like five or ten
years or something like that that's not
the same as TSA pre-check you could get
it together yeah it just comes with it
so then now when you come back through
like International like in custom and
stuff like that I don't even need to uh
go through customs you don't need to
take the picture there's the global
entry thing and you don't even pull out
your passport or ID anymore now it's
just facial recognition like a [__]
iPhone last time close to the machine it
takes your photo and then they call your
name and then you walk on that's tight
suddenly I just walked now it was so
annoying coming coming back yesterday
and then the guy that runs the global
entry thing he's like all happy like
come on come on through global entry and
everyone's like yeah yeah everyone's
hyped and then and then I'm like [__] I
didn't get this [__] but is the process
the same as getting TSA pre-check you
have to go to the place you have to get
the you get both correct okay so now one
interview what are your weaknesses
if I work too hard and then on your next
international flight when you come back
through La at in the baggage claim area
there's an office for an interview so
you set up your interview there oh okay
is it nervous do you get nervous when
you get interviewed dude not if you
don't I got so lucky so did I get the
job or can you just do it once you land
you have to apply first okay so apply it
and then yeah so shout outs to the uh
the the TSA police guys
because on my first interview I had a
fan
my second interview
there was a yeah another the guy that
was interviewing me internet troll the
cop that was interviewing me he wasn't a
fan but his partner was so when he
walked by he goes oh he goes I've seen
you but the way he said it was like
you're a repetitive offender because
because the guy that was looking at me
and doing my uh renewal he was like how
like his face got all like oh [__]
should I watch out for this guy problem
yeah and then I was dying because I was
like oh [__] no I'm not I'm not like a
criminal or anything like that
and then because of your stories that's
why no no no he's a fan so the other
guy's a fan but the way he said it was
like yeah I know who you are like like
you're a [__] Troublemaker like that
yeah and then he was and then like every
he he told him like he watches JK and
all that and then everything was just
about like that and then they're just
they're not even asking me questions and
[__] they're like oh okay cool cool all
right we'll be done yeah cause it's all
on YouTube yeah yeah they know why
you're traveling yeah they're like I
don't think he's a terrorist yeah yeah
exactly you know what I think I'm gonna
do this I think I I've you guys
convinced me to get some Global Entry I
think I've gotten the courage there's a
global entry brand deal right here let's
go together let's go let's go dude let's
book a international trip together I'll
go to London yeah come on
let's do it ride the [__] double
decker bus I've always wanted to I've
always wanted to do that too honey the
double decker the only thing is global
entry is so convenient and fast that
when you come out through customs like
you beat your bags by like 15 minutes I
don't like that but I like that because
I'm always taking a nice long [__] when
I get down to the baggage claim area is
that is that your move it's my move
every single time you go down the
escalators LAX and then you take a left
because the the men's restroom's in the
corner over there airport tip you know
wow there's your airport they leave that
there because if you want to swallow
drugs at the last minute before you get
through
yeah that's smart fun fun fact too I
don't know if this is still true for
Chase Sapphire the credit card but they
also pay for your TSA and Global Entry
they give you 100 credits oh I have a I
have Sapphire that's tight oh it's one
sign up huh it's on sign up you might
still get 100 credit
so basically you'll pay for a hundred
dollar uh
um application I think I got the email
too let's get rebated to your credit
card oh really okay cool
Sapphire also should give you lounge
access for real it's true bro I've
always wanted lounge access I I walk by
the lounges and I feel like a poor
person that's when I feel like would
have missed my flight because then I
it's too chill it's so it is really
chill see all the breakfast oh you know
the you know
the drinks cup of noodles even oh I
remember another stupid time I missed
the flight this is good I was look my I
have my calendar set to four time zones
so I have like London La Hawaii and in
Japan right and I'm never in those so
one time I had it set to a separate time
zone and then I was at the airport like
three hours late or something oh [__]
because I was going back to Hawaii
thinking that yeah [__]
dude I'd be pissed I'd be so mad were
you really upset what happened like
what's your remote like emotionally how
do you feel it I used to just I used to
get mad a lot and like just get mad at
myself a lot yes but then nowadays
uh sir sir please stop doing that I
think nowadays I'm better at controlling
my I'm just I don't want to get mad I'm
just like let's just deal with this yeah
but before I would probably be pissed
for 24 hours talking [__] to myself yeah
just hitting your [__] forehead
I like I like seeing that in the airport
that's actually really funny because you
know when you sit there for a long time
you see people going through so many
emotions yeah yeah it is I do like
people watching people watching airports
yes the funniest thing that we ever saw
in the airport this [__] uh there was
just like fat white guy like with his
back against the wall and he was asleep
and he had his legs like this and then
we were just like looking at him because
he kept like going like that
and then out of nowhere he like farted
and he woke himself up he went like this
one
and he farted so [__] loud and
everybody started laughing at him those
cheeks are rumbling yeah his legs went
like this too he shot one out he
probably got some hang time too what do
you people watch you go like man having
kids and traveling seems like a terrible
[__] nightmare it makes you not want
to have kids because you go like there's
nothing for them to do like there's
nothing there's nothing you can do about
it you can't even get mad honestly yeah
some of them do and it's that's even
crazier like what the [__] yeah yeah
that's a parent I'd probably be crazy I
saw these grandparents like uh taking
care of this toddler right and then so
they can't really move that fast and
then he gets his own like push cart
thingy and then he starts pushing it and
just books it all the way down and then
grandma's trying to catch him in a
[__] die
is she sleeping on the plane I can never
sleep I can pass out so he's like and
meet people like you wait what like
anybody you can sleep at the airport or
sleep on a plane I envy them I I sleep
from minute one till [__] Landing
because like it's like I feel like a
baby but I have to strap I always have
to put the seat belt uh why like this oh
you'll hit people yeah so every time I
go like this and I'm just going the
whole foot
you should just wear a straight jacket
onto this one the people next time are
like stupid stupid
you know what tip does she sleeps bro
she does this she gets a blanket
that's great I did that yesterday and
she'll do that
it looks funny I can be like I can be
reming before takeoff the only time I
have even a moment I'm not like close to
sleeping was like happy
oh yeah is I have to be in the window
seat and I have to like angle myself so
that way my head can be like propped up
right here but I still can't I feel too
like comfortability yeah I can't see
yeah yeah you travel by yourself do you
travel by yourself yeah
that's probably the issue yeah it's like
a vulnerability yeah you have a barrier
between the guy and the random person
next to you it sounds like an opening to
like hit on her like oh you travel by
yourself I mean I'm available
I never travel alone
he's like I'm a fighter yeah I'll
protect you don't don't worry you can
sleep like I'm a really good middle seat
I'm so good at middling
yeah what seeds do you guys like I hope
I like the aisle now me too I like items
no you know when I was a kid I loved the
window I feel too close for phobic aisle
because I like peeing a lot it makes no
difference to me at all I'll take middle
I'm asleep I don't even know I'm in the
middle seat I can't do aisle because my
[__] legs are too long and the car so
people will oh yeah so if I'm trying to
sleep and then I'm constantly getting
woken up like that [__] pisses me off
one time this guy was trying to steal
like he was a big dude he was way bigger
than me and he was trying to steal like
he was his knees were wide open so I was
like all right I could play this [__]
game too dude so you put it over like
this I do the same [__] I did it right
these are always like yes my knees are
touching I'm like I know I'm more
comfortable with physical skin touch
than that guy is and I Advanced shoulder
like this I eventually [__] won yeah
but you know the whole slightly yeah I
could play this game
you guys are on the aisle and the window
seat doing that the guys in the middle
[Laughter]
[Music]